JONATHAN BERI: Now, I'd like
to kick off with some easy
questions, and raise your hand
if this applies to you.
Who's here that has ever
done a Hangout?
OK, in a room about 400
people, everybody
raises their hand.
Now this question, I always
love to hear the answer.
Who's here met somebody truly
interesting in either a
limited or a public Hangout, and
now you engage with them
on a regular basis?
Raise your hand.
All right.
About 25% of the room.
This is new.
This is the next generation of
social, and it's in a Hangout.
So who am I?
I am Jonathan Beri, and I'm
the developer advocate for
Google+ Hangouts.
And today we're going to talk
about the Hangouts, the
Hangouts as a platform, and
we're going to begin by
talking about the
Hangouts story.
The Hangouts story-- how an
internal tool that we were
testing with became a global
communication service.
And we're going to go into some
demos of people building
on top of the platform and
making compelling experiences
within Hangouts.
And here, live onstage, I'm
actually going to build a
Hangout app in front
of all of you.
And to kick us off, I'd like
to introduce Amit Fulay,
project manager for
Google+ Hangouts.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT FULAY: Thanks, Jonathan.
Thank you to everyone in the
room for joining us and those
on the live stream.
We have a great session
planned for you today.
I want to begin by telling
you how the Hangouts
platform came about.
We built Hangouts product as
part of the Google+ project,
as a new way of doing social.
It is live, it is face-to-face,
and you can do
things together.
We wanted to mimic
the real life.
This is how you socialize
in the real world.
And the product has been hugely
successful since we launched.
We've seen it being used
to the most amazing
and creative ways.
We've seen guitar lessons
happen, cooking classes happen
in Hangouts.
We've seen the President of the
United States hang out.
Heck, we even saw guys
jumping off a
plane to be in a Hangout.
How cool was that
in the morning?
But when we started this
project, we wanted to build
something for the users to do
when they'd get in a Hangout.
So we took our existing
YouTube Player, built
an app out of it.
You could come in, you can
search through videos, you can
queue them up.
You can have this real social
viewing experience.
Then we started looking at the
usage of Hangouts, and we
realized Hangouts
were being used
increasingly in business settings.
And one of the tools you want
in that environment is the
ability to collaborate over
docs and presentations.
So we took our Google Docs and
created an app out of that.
And we looked at the usage of
these two things, the YouTube
app and the Docs app.
And we quickly realized, the
best way to take this ahead is
to create APIs around our
functionality and give it in
the hands of all of
you developers.
So we launched the Google+
Hangouts platform a little
over three months ago.
It's open to all developers.
Anyone can write and
distribute an app.
And as soon as we launched, we
started to see a lot of unique
activities come online.
Here's an example
of a poker game.
This small company acted on
a very simple but kind of
obvious insight, which is,
poker is best played when
you're face to face.
So they took our API and
they built this app.
You get in a Hangout, you launch
the game, you take a
seat at the table, the
cards are dealt.
And as you go around, whoever's
turn it is, their
live video shows up in the main
window of the Hangout.
Simple.
Engaging.
Just like real life.
Here's another example of a
start-up in San Francisco
called Scoot & Doodle that
built a doodling app.
And it, again, turned out
to be really popular.
You get in, you get
to pick a color,
you're doodling together.
It's the same canvas.
It's synced in real time.
You can play Pictionary,
teach art, learn art,
and just have fun.
And it turned out, as we saw
these activities come
together, users were spending
2 and 1/2 times more than
those Hangouts.
That is 2 and 1/2 times more
in the app that you write.
We started to see another class
of usage for our API.
People were trying to enhance
live conversations.
And it all started
with this slide.
Now, before you laugh, that's
not a real 'stache.
That's the overlay of
an image on my face.
And there's a reason I put this
slide here, because I
want to tell you a story.
A couple of engineers on our
team looked at the capability
that we had in the platform.
We could detect faces of people
in a Hangout and their
features with pinpoint
accuracy.
So they built this prototype--
a silly little thing.
You could put a mustache
on the face.
And they're like, we should
do something with it.
So I go to my marketing team,
and I said, hey, we have this
new feature in Hangouts.
It's a mustache feature.
And they were like, wow!
That's brilliant!
Really?
Turns out they were running
a Movember campaign.
This was last November.
So they turned this
on in Hangout.
So we put a little button
that said Mustache.
It randomly picked mustaches
and put an
overlay on people's faces.
Within hours, the stream was
full with people taking
pictures of themselves with
a mustache, having fun.
Again, we realized we were
on to something.
Let's build this API, and we've
shipped it again as part
of the platform.
We've also shipped an effects
app that you might have seen.
You can see the accuracy of
overlaying images here.
That's a snorkeling girl
on a live video feed.
And I put that mustache just to
prove that wasn't my real
one in the previous.
We saw developers take
it to another level.
Here's an example of
an app built by a
developer in Germany.
It's a simple app you can use
to support your team.
You come up with a tagline.
You pick the flag
of your country.
It creates this nice little
banner at the bottom.
It stays there when you're
in a Hangout.
A simple little enhancement
to your live conversation.
And you can dynamically
update the message.
Something, again, that
can be very popular.
I'm going to talk about the
third class of usage for the
Hangouts platform.
And this is all about bringing
the power of Hangouts to your
existing app.
Starting with SlideShare.
They have an enormous amount
of content, from
presentations, to
docs, to deck.
They use their API to build a
simple ability to launch a
Hangout with a pre-populated
presentation.
Again, really useful.
You can get in on a Hangout
together and view things.
It saves you a lot of time.
Another example of an
app called Cacoo.
It's a small Japanese company.
They had an existing Chrome
Web Store app.
It's a really good diagramming
software.
You can build things
together, sketches.
You can buy stencils.
What they did was took Hangouts
and brought it into
their app, and it really
lights up.
It saves you so much roundtrip
when you're collaborating with
folks, because you can now get
in a Hangout, get in a live
synchronous conversation,
and get your work done.
Another example of a Norwegian
company called Symphonical.
They took their existing project
management software
and added the powers
of Hangouts to it.
So as you can see, if you are
a developer thinking about
looking at this new platform,
looking at this new way of
socializing which is Google+
Hangouts, there are three ways
you can contribute.
You can build activities inside
of Hangouts, you can
build enhancements for live
conversations, and most
importantly, you can bring
the power of this
face-to-face-to-face platform
to your app.
I have talked a lot
about apps.
Let's see some live demos.
Jonathan, do you want
to start a Hangout?
JONATHAN BERI: Sure.
And I'll invite some our
friends, Amy and
Wolf, to join us.
AMIT FULAY: What I'm going to
show you is three apps that we
announced today we
are featuring.
These are unique apps built
by different teams.
We're going to start with
Google Art Project.
And Jonathan here--
this is a live Hangout--
is joined by Amy and Wolf, who
are our colleagues somewhere
outside of Moscow, and hopefully
not on the roof.
And what we're going to do here
is start looking at art
that interests us.
And as you can see, Amy
likes a painting.
She shares it.
It shows up.
Jonathan can go to that, look
at what interests other
participants in the Hangout.
Now let's take it
a step further.
It turns out, Wolf, in this
Hangout, is a little
bit of an art freak.
Hey, Wolf, how you doing?
JONATHAN BERI: Oh, I don't
think we can hear him.
JONATHAN BERI: Can
you unmute Wolf?
Hey, Wolf. how you doing?
WOLF: Hello.
JONATHAN BERI: There we go.
AMIT FULAY: All right.
We've got a big crowd here.
Do you want to show them
something cool?
WOLF: Sure.
Let me show you this thing.
I really like it.
I'm going to start a tour.
OK.
So this is by a Flemish
Renaissance painter who liked
to paint in sort of an
arbitrary antiquity.
So even though we have a big
kind of Roman Colosseum here.
If you look off to the left,
there is sort of a Flemish
village over here.
JONATHAN BERI: That's
pretty amazing--
WOLF: There's all--
JONATHAN BERI: Oh, sorry.
Go on.
WOLF: No, go ahead.
JONATHAN BERI: I was going to
say, we have this exact same
print in our office and I've
never been able to see this
level of detail before.
WOLF: There's also all kinds of
period construction detail.
If you look at this
here, there's--
this is as far as
we can go in.
There's cranes and all
kinds of things here.
Oh, here is a human-powered
crane over here, with big
wheels that people can run on.
It's really neat.
AMIT FULAY: That is amazing.
Again, you can see, this
is not screen share.
This is different people from
different locations, live in a
Hangout, exploring
art together.
Really engaging.
Really powerful.
It's actually better than real
life, in this specific case.
Let's take a look at
another app here.
Again, we are featuring
this today.
A Story Before Bed.
This is an app built
by a company called
Jackson Fish Market.
And we're going to do a little
bit of role-playing
here for the demo.
Jonathan is young,
you would say.
But he's going to play the role
of a grandfather, and
he's going to try and grab the
attention of those two kids in
the Hangout.
Now, if you've done a Hangout
with a young one, how
difficult is it to keep
them around for
more than 30 seconds?
Impossible?
I would agree.
It's probably tougher than doing
a skydive in a Hangout.
What we're going to try
and do is read a book.
Hopefully they're engaged.
So play the role, Jonathan.
JONATHAN BERI: All
right, kiddies.
Let's read Five Little
Monkeys.
WOLF: Oh boy.
AMY: OK, Grandpa.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
JONATHAN BERI: I'll grab it off
the bookshelf and begin.
Let's open it up.
Aw, there's some monkeys.
"Five little monkeys jumping on
the bed, one fell off and
bumped his head."
AMIT FULAY: All right,
that's good.
That's good.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
JONATHAN BERI: It's
a good one.
AMIT FULAY: I don't
know about you--
AMY: OK, I think we're ready
to go to the end.
AMIT FULAY: But if you're
actually doing these kind of
activities in a Hangout,
you'll probably
lose track of time.
And that's great for
our developers.
Because that's what you want,
attention of your consumers.
We're going to take a look
at another example.
A classic game, pool.
It's always fun to challenge
someone to a game of pool.
We're going to show this app
that's built by Miniclip.
And let's take a look at
the experience, how
it mimics real life.
It's going to load.
We've tried it before.
JONATHAN BERI: Somebody's
streaming this
talk, aren't they?
AMIT FULAY: All right.
There we go.
Let's play pool.
[CHIME SOUNDS ON APP]
[SIMULATED SOUND OF BALLS
BEING RACKED]
JONATHAN BERI: All right.
WOLF: By the way, Jonathan,
I'm really
good at computer pool.
[SIMULATED SOUND OF POOL SHOT]
AMIT FULAY: That was weak.
JONATHAN BERI: I
guess I'm not.
[CHIME SOUNDS ON APP]
WOLF: Remember, thousands of
people just saw you do that.
[SIMULATED SOUND OF POOL SHOT]
AMIT FULAY: All right.
You guys want to keep playing
or should we go to code?
AUDIENCE: Keep playing.
AMIT FULAY: Keep playing?
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
AMIT FULAY: We've got a bunch of
these apps in the demo and
in the Google+ Sandbox, so
you're welcome to try those.
I'm going to hand
it to Jonathan.
Let's switch monitors here.
What I really wanted to do with
these examples and the
demos is give you a glimpse into
what's possible in this
new way of doing social.
And how to make it happen?
What's the mechanics behind
writing these apps?
I'm going to hand it back to
Jonathan, who will walk you
through that.
JONATHAN BERI: Great,
thank you, Amit.
I want to begin with a story.
A story about two developers,
Joshua and Charles.
Now, Joshua and Charles really
enjoy playing role-playing
board games, and they've been
using video chat technology to
enable themselves to play with
other fans around the world.
And while it lets them play
the game, it actually adds
complexity.
They've got to fiddle with the
camera, make sure it's facing
the board, back at their face,
back at the board again.
They've got to deal
with managing
cards, rolling the dice.
It's got to be in the frame,
because you don't want to be
blamed for cheating.
And it's just cumbersome.
So when we launched the
developer platform last year,
they both jumped on it and
said, this is the best
platform to bring RPG
games online.
They started developing a
framework for RPG games, and
of course they discovered each
other through Hangouts and
started collaborating.
It became wildly successful,
and they decided to start a
modest Kickstarter of $8,000
to help fund for
licenses and designs.
$5,000.
All right.
In less than 24 hours,
they met their goal.
I think last time we checked, it
was about $19,000, $20,000
from volunteers.
And about 900 folks were
investing in what is now
Tabletop Forge.
This is an opportunity.
This is real.
Users want to have
these types of
experiences inside of Hangouts.
And honestly, if you're not
building the next Tabletop
Forge, somebody else will.
So let's look at what you can do
within a Hangout by talking
about some scenarios you
might want to build.
OK.
Let's say you wanted to build a
poker game, and you want it
to have a table.
And you want it to show when
people are at the poker table
and when they leave.
So we have APIs that let you
access information about who's
in the Hangout, the Google+
profile information, like
their picture, and actually
respond to events when they
join or leave the Hangout.
So you can make that
poker table like a
real life poker table.
All right.
Let's say you want to build a
drawing application where,
when somebody in the Hangout
draws a path, it shows up in
everybody else's Hangout.
And also, you want them to
have their own color and
synchronize that color.
Well, we have data
channel APIs.
The data channel APIs allow you
to easily synchronize app
state across everybody in the
Hangout, as well as high-speed
data, like that smooth curve
you want to see.
And that's built on Google's
infrastructure, so you don't
have to build a crazy
amount of servers to
do a real-time system.
Now let's say you want to go
all the way with a fun
interactive application.
Say, dress up like a unicorn and
catch falling doughnuts.
Well, you can do that.
Now, this is an actual
application that was built in
an experiment we did last
month where we have
face-tracking overlays that
move with your facial
positions, like this unicorn
head, and the ability to
respond to movement
in real time.
And that's how you can catch
those amazing doughnuts.
Now that what you can do, let's
talk about how you can
do that, by looking at
the building blocks
of a Hangout app.
And it all starts with the
JavaScript and HTML that you
write, which is your application
code, and the
features of a Hangout.
Let's look at the JavaScript
first.
Right here is the simplest
Hangout app ever.
And you'll notice
that it's XML.
And we take that XML-- it's just
boilerplate, but it forms
the foundation for
your application.
What you really care about is
the little bit of JavaScript
wrapped in a CDATA tag.
And that CDATA tag is what we
serve inside of a Hangout.
And we take that and it's
iFramed into the Hangout
experience.
We also allow you to serve an
iFrame from your own servers.
Let me repeat that.
We allow you to serve an iFrame
from your own servers
inside of a Hangout app.
If you only take away one thing
from this entire talk
about the technical implications
of a Hangout app,
it's that anything you
can do in an iFrame,
you can do in a Hangout.
Anything you can do
in an iFrame,
you can do in a Hangout.
That means you can use the
technologies that you're
comfortable with and the
environment you like to build
in to develop Hangout apps.
This is probably my most
favorite feature of Hangout
app development.
So that means you can use the
server-side technologies you
like to use, whether it be
Python on App Engine, Ruby on
Rails-- no JS.
You can use the database
technologies
that scale for you.
MySQL, NoSQL, YourSQL,
HerSQL--
anything under the sun.
And of course, you can use the
environments and the IDEs that
work best for you.
So if you have an existing game
with aliens and laser
blasters, you can easily bring
that into Hangout.
And if you have a new game that
you want to build, a new
application, it's easy to
migrate it onto the Hangout
apps platform.
Now let's go over the features
of a Hangout, which is
encapsulated in the
Hangout JS.
I mentioned that everything
is a JavaScript.
So we have a single JavaScript
file that you include inside
your application, and it gives
you access to all the rich
features of a Hangout that you
can include inside your
application.
Things like participant
information--
so who was at that
poker table?
The data channels, the
high-speed smooth curve of
that drawing.
Other things, like
the audio-video
effects, the overlays.
And other metadata about the
Hangout, like the Hangout ID
and the URL.
And with this one simple
JavaScript include, you have
the power of Hangouts within
your application.
Great.
It's now time to show
you how easy it is.
On this stage, you'll probably
hear other people saying that
it's easy to build something
on Google.
But I have the luxury that I can
actually code it live here
in front of all of you
in the live stream.
Quick question--
who's played Guess the Pastry?
OK, I guess I'm the
only one who codes
while they're hungry.
So I'm going to build a very
simple application.
All it's going to do is
show a picture of a
pastry to the audience--
to the players, rather--
they have to guess, and
they get a prize.
So what I'm going to do is
first show who's playing,
using the API, and list all the
participants in the Hangout.
Then I'm going to take a guess
and validate whether
it's true or not.
And the winners will get
a web badge of honor.
And by web badge of
honor, I mean--
yeah, the Nyan Cat.
All right.
Let's get started.
And if you guys notice any
syntax errors or spelling
mistakes, please feel free to
shout it out, because this is
partly collaborative.
Now, to build on the Google+
platform, or any platform at
Google, you have to
first start at the
Google Developer Console.
That's where you create a new
project and enable the
services you want to integrate
with that project.
So I'm going to go ahead and
create a new project.
Let's go head and create.
I'm going to call this
Guess the Pastry.
And once it's finished loading,
we now have a new
project called Guess
the Pastry.
You'll see here, there's a bunch
of Google services that
you can use.
We're just interested
in Hangouts today.
So to enable that service
within this project, I
go from Off to On.
Now, scrolling up, you may have
caught that there's a now
Hangout tab.
And that is the most
important tab for
developing this Hangout.
And there's a bunch
of stuff here.
There's a place to
do descriptions,
icons, privacy policy.
But the most important thing is
you tell Google where your
XML, where your application
is hosted.
It's got to be publicly hosted,
so I'm going to throw
it up on an app engine, and
as we develop we can
move on from there.
I actually have a starter
project kicked off with some
boilerplate.
And we're going to go ahead and
publish this to the App
Engine right now, and we'll
see what this looks like.
So I go back to our hosting
service, choose that file,
it's on the--
gonna cheat there.
So I have a URL for this XML.
It's now publicly available.
Let's verify that is the case.
And this is what
the Application
Store will look like.
But it's not a Hangout
app yet until I
publish it to my project.
Great.
So once I save it, there's a URL
to the Developer Sandbox.
I click this off.
It's firing up a Hangout.
This is the Developer
Sandbox environment.
It's not publicly available, so
you can-- don't worry about
while you're developing to
expose it to other users.
Now I'm in here, and we
have our application.
So there's the Guess the Pastry,
and the picture and
the form field.
So now let's go ahead and add
some-- let's look at the code
that we had in the boilerplate
before we begin adding some
functionality.
So you'll recognize this
XML from earlier.
It's just the boilerplate.
And I have some empty functions
and some functions
that I've started already.
So let's look at the HTML
part, because that's the
simplest of what you
can see now.
Here we have a header tag, an
image, which is the pastry,
and some form fields.
And that's really about it.
The first piece of the API
is already started.
And what we want to do is wait
for the API to be initialized.
And there's a simple event
listener, which is the
hangout.onApiReady.
And you notice that everything
is prefixed with gapi.
So everything is namespaced,
it's logical, and the
documentation matches that.
So it's really easy to
start developing.
Let's go ahead and start
our first API call.
I'm actually going to do this
directly within the Hangout,
because the beauty of building
JavaScript applications is you
can test it while
it's running.
And the Chrome Developer Console
has some great tools
to develop with.
Let's clear that out.
So all I have to do
is make sure I'm
in the Hangout itself.
And I can start calling
something in the
gapi.hangout namespace.
Right?
Ooh, I gotta spell
correctly first.
So the first thing I want to
do is show who is in the
Hangout, so what I'm going
to do is call the
getParticipants method.
And what that'll do is return
an array of all the
participants in the Hangout.
You'll notice there's only
one, which is me.
So there should only
be one entry.
Let's call it and see
what it returns.
This is an array of objects.
And you can see, if I look into
the person, that's me.
Jon Beri.
And so we're going to use that
function right now to get the
list of participants and
display it inside the
application.
So going back to the code, what
I want to do is have this
function called
showParticipants.
And I'm going to
do var party =
gapi.hangout.getParticipants.
So I got that object.
Next we're going to just
loop through it
and set it as a string.
So var display +=, let's do
a People and do an
unordered list.
And now let's do party.forEach
function, let's do player.
So now we're going to iterate
through that array.
And what I want to do is display
an  element for
each participant.
And we're just going
to do , and--
yeah, let's do it this way.
We'll do--
break it up.
Display += and I want to do
player.Person.displayName.
And we're going to close
up that element.
OK, so we're listing everybody
who's in the Hangout.
Let's just do a simple
display.
Close up the URL.
It's hard to type on
a Windows machine.
And then, so you've
closed that up.
And what we're going to do is
insert that into an element
that we have stored, which
is just the div =
document.querySelector.
And then I want to
do #participants.
So I'm grabbing this simple
display  and setting its
inner HTML to--
OK, this is display.
Right?
And that should iterate and
spit out everything
we want it to do.
So let's go back to this
hosting device.
I'm going to choose to make sure
that I got the right one.
Great.
Open.
Re-upload.
And we should now see
it as we refresh.
OK.
So nothing is being displayed.
That's because we haven't
called that method.
So what I'm going to
do is manually
call that method again.
Oh, there's a token error.
Ooh.
Did anybody catch that?
AUDIENCE: 19.
JONATHAN BERI: 19.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN BERI: Oh, good call.
Thanks.
So we upload again.
I told you this gets
collaborative after a while.
Cool.
No syntax error, and now
it's being displayed.
So what we want to do is call
that when the application
starts and every time
somebody joins.
So the next thing we'll
do is register--
we've actually already had
this registered, so the
gapi.hangout.onParticipant is
the first event that we want
to register for.
And I've done something
really simple here.
All I've done was call the
showParticipant again, so it
just keeps on looping
and checking the
gapi.getParticipants object
and redisplaying it.
It's clean.
It's not very efficient, but
it gets the point across.
So now the guess piece.
When somebody makes a guess,
we actually call the
JavaScript function directly
from the onclick handler.
So I'm going to go fill
up that guess.
And for this example, all I want
to do is just store the
fact that they've guessed.
I'm not going to do anything
fancy with the shared-state
functionality.
And that's all I'm going
to do, is call the
shared-state API.
And the shared-state API is a
key value pair of strings,
very easy to use, and it's
guaranteed across all
participants.
So the call is
gapi.hangout.data--
again, another namespace--
.setValue.
And the key we're going to use
is the actual person's ID, the
Hangout ID.
And so there's a method
for that too, which is
gapi.hangout.getParticipants.
Sorry, not the easiest
word to spell.
By ID.
And that's going to be the
key to our key value.
And then the value will just
be a string that's true.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN BERI: OK, yeah.
Thanks, Gerwin.
Another save by Gerwin.
It's very simple.
This is just going to
push that value.
And we actually look that up.
So anybody in a Hangout from the
API can call and check any
value in the shared state,
which is very useful,
especially with this
asynchronous-type application.
And the call is, as you
can guess, getValue.
So what I'll do is, I'll add a
getValue for the hasGuessed
method, and we can use that
by passing in the ID from
somewhere and retrieving it.
Now it's just
gapi.hangout.data.getValue.
And it's going to be the ID.
But to actually check what the
value is, we're using strings.
And so I actually
have to check if
that's a valid string.
It's not a true, like as
a Boolean operator.
So we'll just do a simple
if-else statement, right?
It's saying if--
and I gotta attach this to
a var guessed equals.
So if ( guessed === "true"),
we're just
going to return true.
Else, return false.
This is a simple check.
So now let's go ahead
and save this.
Go back to the hosting
and push it to
the app engine server.
OK, so it's updated.
Refresh the application.
And put in any string, right?
OK.
Now to verify that actually
worked, because we're not
responding to that function,
let's go ahead and call
gapi.hangout.data.getState.
And what this will do is just
dump the entire state object,
the entire collection
of key in value.
And you can see that this is
actually my participant ID
that I just guessed with, and
the value I said was true.
So this is actually being
saved and persisted.
Now for the last piece is the
web badge of honor, and that's
the Nyan Cat.
And this is using
our av.effects.
And we're going to do
a very simple thing.
We're just going to display a
static image of a Nyan Cat if
I guess correctly, and then from
there, I can position it.
But we're just going to render
it straight on the video feed.
So I've actually started
this here.
Well, I've actually already
completed this here, but let's
walk through it.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to grab the value
of the text box, and that's--
just ID it as guess and
check for the answer.
I have an answer variable
stored up here, and the
correct answer is 'nom.' OK.
Not exactly a pastry, but
it's easy and fast.
And then what we're going to
do is, again, call our
gapi.hangout object and
do an av.effects and
create an image resource.
And when you create an image
resource, we just pass in a
URL of a publicly-accessible
image, and that
loads it into memory.
It's not being displayed.
It's not being shown, but it's
available for us to access.
So all we have to do at that
point is set showOverlay.
And showOverlay will, by
default, render that image and
center it at full size
on the video feed.
We can also pass in
configuration information,
like scaling it, and
offsetting it,
and positioning it.
But for this demo, we just
want to have this.
And what we'll do is, whenever
they guess we'll call
guessedCorrectly.
And that will look up to verify
that they actually
guessed correctly, and
if it does work, it
should show an overlay.
Let's re-upload it to the app
engine server, refresh this
and make sure I can be
in frame, reset,
and see if this works.
There we go.
Nyan Cat.
So I guessed right.
That's it for this
application.
As you can see, it's
simple but it's
actually very powerful.
I've touched on a bunch of the
lowest-level APIs that are
sort of core to what
you want to do.
And we actually have
a functioning app
in, what, 10 minutes?
So imagine, if you want to build
your application, how
quickly you would get it up and
running and focusing on
building a fun, more powerful
user experience.
Now this was just very
high-level, but we actually
have a Code Lab that takes a
deep dive in later today.
That looks like it's going
to be a space-themed one.
So definitely check it out.
The Code Lab link is here,
for those who are
watching on live stream.
And it's going to go from
everything from walking you to
getting you up and running
and advanced
techniques on debugging.
Definitely check it out.
Now, Google's built several
applications.
You saw some of them today.
And we've worked with many other
partners who've launched
initially, and more have
come out today.
And we've learned a lot.
You know, when you build a
platform, it's not always easy
to see the vision in the future
of what people are
going to do with it.
So we have a lot of lessons
learned from building these
applications, and we want to
pass them onto you so when you
get started, you can build the
best user experience that you
can within a Hangout app.
So the first insight we have,
which may seem obvious, is put
people first.
You're building a social
application, a multi-user
social application.
So that means people are doing
things within your
application.
Things are flying around
the screen.
So you need to make sure that
you identify who's doing what
within the context of
the application.
So use the Google+ profile
picture if you can.
Attach overlays or colorize, and
somehow distinguish users
as they're interacting to make
it easier for everybody else
to know who's doing the turn.
The next insight we
have is social
is about being together.
From the fundamental level of
your application design, it
should be collaborative
and synchronous.
See, Hangouts are not
really interesting
when you're by yourself.
You have a mirror for that.
And when you go to two people
or even three people, it's
just a little bit better
than a video chat.
But it gets magical when
you get to five, ten.
Or public Hangouts-- they can
go to hundreds and hundreds.
So make sure that everything
you do is collaborative and
synchronous.
And make the games
really sticky.
Users will join when you
least expect it.
Like this poor monkey who didn't
see this other one
flying at him, the way that
people find, discover, and
join Hangouts is through the
stream, which is real-time,
notifications, and
mobile updates.
So people will be joining
Hangouts at random intervals.
There won't be a start time and
an end time, unless you do
events, and that might be
a little bit better.
But if you're doing an
application, or let's say a
game, it can interrupt
the flow.
So we've built into the system
many callbacks that trigger
whenever events happen, so you
can make your applications
respond correctly when
somebody joins.
So there are a ton of
Participant callbacks.
And use them liberally
and intelligently.
The next thing that we learned
was that playing alongside
friends can be fun, too.
The classic use case of a
Hangout app is having 10
people, all in a room at
the same time, using an
application together.
But there's different ways
you can group things.
If you saw, in the pool app,
we were playing two-on-two.
In that application, you can
actually play multiple games
of two-on-two.
And what's that like?
That's like real life.
That's like a pool hall, where
you have multiple games with
people who can trash-talk to
each other, can comment on
technique, or maybe learn
from each other.
There's even other ways
of dividing it, right?
You could have a semi-private
mode, where you only see part
of your world and everybody else
has a shared experience.
Or something that we have not
seen yet, which I'm hoping you
guys come up with, which
is the MMO style.
So you could have n-many
Hangouts, all participating in
the same shared space and
interacting together.
I think that's really
interesting and compelling.
So think about different ways
you can group users within
your application.
And make sure that you react.
Make sure you react
immediately and
respond in real time.
Like this poor guy, he wasn't
following the ball and got hit
in the face.
Similar to the way that
participants join a Hangout,
they interact with your
application in real time.
We have data channels, and we
encourage the interactivity
and responsiveness of
your application.
So you have to make sure that
you respond to things that are
happening, because the user
experience will be broken if
there's delays or if the
flow is not great.
So make sure you take advantage
of these high-speed
Google-powered data channels
to synchronize your
applications.
And you saw it was quick
and easy to implement.
And now, back to Amit.
AMIT FULAY: Thanks, Jonathan.
I think that was great.
So in the last 45 minutes, we've
looked at how we started
with building a platform with
this Hangouts product.
We're still early.
We're learning, and we're always
looking for feedback
from you guys.
We looked at some demos to give
you a sense of what's
possible, and you saw Jonathan
take you through the details
of what it takes to
build an app.
I think the road ahead of us,
for all of us in this room, is
full of possibilities.
I think we have, for the first
time, a way to reimagine the
web with live synchronous
conversations and activities.
This wasn't possible
a few years ago.
This was certainly not possible
at this scale and
free of cost.
So I encourage all of you to
take a look at what we've
built and join us
in the journey.
With that, here's
some pointers to
how can you get started.
We also have a Code Lab later
today at 4 o'clock.
Following the session, we also
have a fireside chat with some
more members of the
Hangouts team.
We will talk about aspects
of our product
beyond the app platform.
We'll talk about Hangouts On
Air, mobile, and where we're
going in the future with this
communications platform.
With that, I think we'll
take questions.
Thanks for being patient.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT FULAY: We've got two mics
on the sides, if you want to
ask a question.
JONATHAN BERI: And speak loudly
so the people on video
can hear you.
AUDIENCE: Are there persistent
Hangouts, or can you
programmatically create an
instance of a Hangout?
AMIT FULAY: Persistent, as
in, they live forever?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like you don't
need a person to host it.
It's just there and people
could show up.
AMIT FULAY: Yeah, we have a
notion of named Hangouts,
where you have a fixed URL.
And we can use that in
the meetings context.
We had this as part of what we
call as Hangouts With Extras,
and we folded it into one
product, Hangouts.
And we're going to introduce
it pretty soon, with
integration with Calendar
and stuff.
So you can create a meeting,
have a fixed URL, and anybody
can drop in at any time.
JONATHAN BERI: And to add to
that, you mentioned how could
you programmatically
create Hangouts?
Well, we don't have, let's
say, a REST-based API to
generate Hangouts, but we do
have this notion of the
Hangout button.
And the Hangout button
is pretty awesome.
It's a simple link you
add to your website.
We have an image for that.
And it could do three things.
One, it could launch a brand new
Hangout from your site, or
from an ad, or from anywhere
else in the web.
It can launch a Hangout
with an app preloaded.
And it can launch a new Hangout
with an app preloaded,
plus you can pass in
initialization data.
So for example, if you're a
publisher and you have a
football team's page, you can
actually build a custom
application using the Hangout
apps platform and have a
button, say, Talk About
the Broncos.
And that will launch a new
Hangout with your app
preloaded, and it'll say, hey,
this guy was on the Broncos
page, and actually show that
state of the Broncos app.
I think we had a question
and they sat down.
OK, great.
AMIT FULAY: And for those of you
leaving the room, if you
liked this session, there's
those +1 cards.
Put those in the box.
If you didn't, you can
just walk out.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: So we set up a few
MacBook Pros, maybe four
MacBook Pros, to capture
a presenter at a gTalk.
So we wanted to basically
broadcast different dimensions
of the speakers, standing up,
using the whiteboard, and just
capture the volume.
And we noticed that the
MacBooks, they all seemed to
timeout after a period
of time.
Not the screensaver, but it
seemed like the Hangout.
And of course, we just
left them on some
seats just to stream.
So I'm wondering, is there a
stay-alive command that you
can pipe through or some sort
of scripting you can do to
kind of ping the Hangout if
you're streaming, without
somebody to rock the laptop?
AMIT FULAY: Yeah.
So I think what you're referring
to is the timeout
that we have built in.
After 90 minutes, if you're
inactive Hangouts,
we time those out.
And we built that provision in
to kind of safeguard against
abuse and using it for scenarios
that we didn't want.
But that's great feedback, and
we're actively looking on how
to change that configuration.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Can you create Hangout
apps on Android?
AMIT FULAY: So that's
a big question.
We don't have support for
Hangout apps on the phone, but
we're looking at an option
in the coming days.
And once we have something to
announce, you'll hear it.
AUDIENCE: Will you be making
the code that you were just
putting up available?
JONATHAN BERI: So, yes.
So the question was, will I be
making the code available.
Definitely.
It's actually publicly available
now, because I was
pushing it live to production.
AMIT FULAY: Google
Guess the Pastry.
JONATHAN BERI: And I'll just--
I'll post it on my
Google+ stream.
If you're not following me, you
probably should, if you're
interested in Hangouts.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
JONATHAN BERI: And this is
actually just a more advanced
version of some of
our samples.
So if you saw the link up there,
that's our developer
site for everything to do with
Hangout apps for developers.
And in there, we have about 10
different samples that go from
very basic, you know, this
is the boilerplate to get
started, to making fun overlays
and using the facial
movement response API.
So definitely check those out.
And follow my stream.
AUDIENCE: Can you into include
Flash as part of the Google
Hangout apps?
Like a Flash player or
a Flash application?
JONATHAN BERI: That it's
a great question.
Actually, what you saw today--
AMIT FULAY: We have
had Flash games.
JONATHAN BERI: The pool game was
actually built in Flash.
So because you can serve it from
your own iFrame, because
you can figure out the cross
domain and all those issues
that are kind of hard without
an iFrame, you can serve a
Flash game, or Flash player.
AUDIENCE: Can you say a little
bit about what your plans are
with higher resolution and
higher frame-rate video, and
where that's going over time?
AMIT FULAY: I think the best
place to ask that question is
in the next fireside chat.
I think those folks who work on
that aspect might be able
to answer that.
Any other questions?
Comments?
JONATHAN BERI: I will say that
some of those apps that we
demoed are turned on in
production already.
So they're in the Featured
section of Hangouts.
So you can give them
a try right now.
Actually, in the front row,
some of our community
developers are here, so if you
have questions that you didn't
feel like asking on camera,
you can ask these guys,
because they're pretty
awesome.
AUDIENCE: This question might be
more for the fireside chat,
but I'll ask it anyway.
Are there any plans to unify
Hangouts, Google Chat,
Messenger in the near future?
AMIT FULAY: That's
a great question.
I think that's a problem we're
thinking about, and you'll
hear more in the next session.
JONATHAN BERI: And we've already
made some inroads on
that, right?
So when somebody invites you
to hang out, we send an IM.
And there's other touch
points where you
can launch a Hangout.
So definitely something
we're looking into.
AUDIENCE: If you wrote a great
app and you want to promote
it, what's--
are those apps also
in the apps list?
AMIT FULAY: Yeah.
So the apps that are visible
within a Hangout on the apps
list, those are the
featured apps.
Think of those as Staff Picks or
Editors' Picks that we have
on Chrome App Store and
Android Market.
So we have a team that carefully
goes through a bunch
of apps and promotes those.
And we look at that all the
time, so if we find something
compelling, we promote those.
But having said that, I think
there's various ways for you
to distribute apps widely.
You can have--
Jonathan talked about the +
Hangout button, where you can
embed a button with
an app launcher.
You can do that on the Google+,
on your + page.
You can do it on your
own website.
Once you have a Hangout app
that's loaded in, that sticks
within your recent list.
So we kind of remember
all the things that
you've played with.
It's there for easy recall.
And you can share that
app with other
folks within a Hangout.
AUDIENCE: How about the
Chrome Web Store?
AMIT FULAY: What about
So are you referring to
distributing apps through
Chrome Web Store?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If you have a Hangout app you
want to put it out on Web
Store, is it--?
AMIT FULAY: So that's, again,
something we're looking at.
We have nothing to announce
right now.
Hey, [? Mart ?].
AUDIENCE: What about Flash and
GIF support as an overlay?
JONATHAN BERI: Ooh, Flash--
so Flash as an overlay and
GIF as an overlay.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Right now, you can only
add PNGs and JPGs.
JONATHAN BERI: And we also
support data URIs.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
JONATHAN BERI: So the data URI
was recently introduced to add
a lot more flexibility.
I think people are trying to
animate with overlays now.
I think the first thing we're
going to do is try to support
that better.
Make the ability to switch on
and off overlays first before
we look to other formats.
I'm not quite sure Flash
would ever make sense.
It may be just not a capability
we want to explore.
But that's great feedback
around the GIFs.
AUDIENCE: Another question is,
when you create an overlay or
an image resource, you
allocate memory.
And there's still some kind of
memory leak, because the
resources you allocate
never get released.
So if you created a lot of
resources, at some point you
exceed your memory.
So is there a fix in the works,
or something you work
on, that this will
be sorted out?
JONATHAN BERI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Good.
JONATHAN BERI: That was
the short answer.
The long answer,
actually, tails
into what I just responded.
By looking at how people are
using the overlays and really
pushing the limits, we've seen
500 image resources of decent
quality being able to run
on a standard machine.
Not even a MacBook Pro.
But obviously, it varies.
So we're going to look into
how we can better help you
manage those resources, how
the plug-in can manage the
resources for you, and how you
can really get awesome types
of animations within
the overlays.
AMIT FULAY: We'll
take a question.
AUDIENCE: So I'm not sure if
this is an Events question or
a Hangouts question, so I'm
posing it in both places.
First of all, tying Hangouts
to Events is huge, for us,
especially.
It's awesome.
Thank you so much.
I know I've been annoying
people with that
question for a while.
What we'd like to do is we'd
like to tie the end of the
Event to the end of the Hangout,
if that's possible.
So right now, we run games.
We run the Tabletop Forge, and
you never know how long the
game is going to go.
Sometimes it'll go two
hours, and sometimes
it goes five hours.
It kind of goes until
it's resolved
itself for the evening.
It would be really nice
if the Event just
spanned that period.
Because initially people will
just add two hours to whatever
they think it's going to be in
order for it not to run out
before the game ends.
Is that in the works
or on the table?
Or should I go talk to the
Events people again?
AMIT FULAY: Yeah, so I don't
know about the definite plans,
but we have some folks I can
connect you with who are
working on integration with
Events, and we can take a look
at this feedback.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
JONATHAN BERI: Thanks.
AMIT FULAY: Just talk to me
after I get off the stage, and
I'll connect you.
Yes sir?
JONATHAN BERI: Please.
AUDIENCE: Three quick questions
related to inviting
agents to a Hangout.
Inviting from within the Sandbox
doesn't seem to work.
AMIT FULAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's no PST and
dialing from within a Hangout
in the Sandbox, to test
PST and calling.
And the other one was, if I have
an agent get invited out
of [INAUDIBLE] to a given
Hangout, the Join
button shows up.
Is there any way to bypass the
Join button or some of the
manual nature of that?
AMIT FULAY: So let me take
the first two here.
The Invite functionality
is disabled.
That's by design.
I think we built the Sandbox
environment as a test bed for
our developers.
And the way to access it is
through a whitelist that the
developer gets to choose.
So while you are in development,
we don't want for
your app to actually get
promoted with the larger
Google+ user base when
you're not ready.
So that's the reason we kind
of kept it that way.
You have to go in the Developer
Console and
explicitly publish your app to
migrate it to the production
environment.
And that's where you'd get
the Invite functionality.
Regarding PST and [? out ?],
again, Sandbox is something
that the Hangouts API team uses
to roll out functionality
quickly, get your feedback
before we graduate things into
production.
It's not a full-fidelity
environment, so we don't put
all the features that we have
in regular Hangouts into the
developer Sandbox.
But if that's something we
expose through our API, we'll
definitely include it
in the Sandbox.
And the third question,
I'm forgetting.
Was--
AUDIENCE: The join button.
JONATHAN BERI: The join flow.
The join flow in develop--
JONATHAN BERI: In developing
environment?
So maybe you can just jump on.
AUDIENCE: It's Hangouts
in general.
If someone comes into a Hangout,
they have to click
Join implicitly to join.
If you're trying to invite an
agent to a call, having to
have them manually click a
Join button is kind of
inconvenient.
AMIT FULAY: OK.
That's good feedback.
OK, we've got time for maybe
one or two more questions.
Then we've got to--
AUDIENCE: It's just
a short question.
If I develop an app for an On
Air Hangout, there is no way
to test it at the moment because
the Sandbox only
provides testing for
regular Hangouts.
Is there something also
coming in the future
to test on-air features?
AMIT FULAY: There's nothing
coming, but you just gave us
something to work on.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
AMIT FULAY: That's
great feedback.
We'll take a look at that.
AUDIENCE: And we just--
since we rolled out On Air we've
added a very limited
functionality to the API
so you can tell if a
Hangout is On Air.
And now that we've seen how
people are using On Air and
Hangout apps, we have all these
great ideas of our own
and some feedback.
And that's definitely something
that we're going to
look at as we expand the
API around On Air.
AMIT FULAY: OK.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
For sure.
Please.
AUDIENCE: So real quick--
the format of Hangouts
is very similar to
OpenSocial in some ways.
I notice there's no mention
of OpenSocial.
Are there any plans to move
towards the OpenSocial
standard for some of this?
Or are you guys completely
giving up on that?
JONATHAN BERI: Sure.
Great question, and we've
gotten it before.
If you've done OpenSocial or if
you've done Google Gadgets
and you're doing Hangouts now,
you'll see there's--
it's part of the DNA from
all that technology.
And actually, Google prides
itself in building a product,
learning from it, and
expanding on it.
So if you look at the early
Google Gadgets to what we have
in Hangouts, you'll see pieces
of all these technologies.
And we're using it in smarter
ways, and better ways, and
applying it specifically
to that environment.
So you're right.
This is not
OpenSocial-compatible, and for
good reason.
OpenSocial is not a Hangout
app platform.
But OpenSocial is a thriving
community, so as we mature
this product and follow where
OpenSocial's going, we'll see
if we can bridge the gap in
some way in the future.
Thanks.
We have time for one question
on stage, but if there's
anybody who wants to ask us
questions one-on-one, we'll be
right outside.
You can follow us out.
And of course we have the
Developer Sandbox for more
one-on-one questions.
Nobody else?
AMIT FULAY: Thank you guys.
Thank you for joining us.
JONATHAN BERI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]